well president Trump is holding a news
conference and quite interestingly in
the last few moments he has just said
that for the last week and a half
he has been taken the unproven malaria
drug hydroxychloroquine let's listen to
what he's just had to say but I get a
lot of tremendously positive news on the
hydroxy and I say hey you know the
expression I've used John what do you
have to lose okay what do you have to
lose I have to take it for about a week
for about a week and a half at some
point every day I take a pill every day
at some point I'll stop what I'd like to
do is I'd like to have the cure and/or
the vaccine and that'll happen I think
very soon zero symptoms now I haven't
had any said no I tested a test every
couple of days they want to test me you
know for obvious reasons I mean I am the
president so they want to test me I
don't want to be tested but they want to
test me so every couple of days I get
tested and I've been I've shown always
negative right negative is that the term
you use for this right negative totally
negative
no symptoms no nothing but no I take it
because I think I hear very good things
again you have to go to frontline
workers many frontline workers take it
and they seem to be doing very well your
family would be surprised I don't want
to ask them because that's a personal
decision as to whether or not you want
to say I just want to be open with the
American public because you know I
happen to think it's good I do want the
letter given because this letter made
not in terms of my taking it but I
thought it was a very well-crafted
letter by a man who's a respected doctor
up in Westchester maybe a little beyond
Westchester a little up higher and in
New York and he just he didn't want
anything he just wanted me to know the
results of what he's doing as a doctor
and he was so happy with the fact that I
I fight for this stuff and then we have
this crazy whistleblower this fake
whistleblower get out and try and you
know knock it who
who will sign the application he did all
this he did the signing he was a
believer at one point I assume otherwise
he shouldn't have signed it